Jonathan our new midlander yes we have
so much to talk about and break down
about the wild experience that is big
brother so let's dive right into it
how are you how are you feeling you know
being out of the house and being in jury
like does it feel real
I mean it feels surreal uh I mean I'm
happy I woke up this morning fulfilled
uh couldn't be happier with the
experience to officer bounds uh the
whole thing was fun uh I mean I met so
many great people in there and uh
I just feel good about the whole
experience so far awesome all right well
as you know the split with it being 4-3
last night so tell me what that says a
bit about the dynamic in the house right
now
well
um
the house is clearly split down the
middle and I feel like Santina is kind
of off on her own trying to find her way
and who to trust in both sides of the
house uh are having trouble trusting her
but uh
I feel like she is definitely a key
piece moving forward because hey she's a
copy bee she's really good at this game
so I'm excited to see exactly where she
falls in the house right now because you
know the lines are drying and teams are
picked and it's going to be a war in
there
hmm okay well I gotta ask you what are
your thoughts about shanea using the
veto to save Renee
honestly my my personal opinion I mean
the house was super upset about it
because uh everyone kind of felt that I
would end up on the Block
um I mean even Tai was offset about a
Thai fight for her not to use it because
he felt like his hands were tired but uh
honestly I get it I mean that was her
friend she had the opportunity to save
her and at the end of the day I can't be
mad at it because I feel like if if I
was the one with the POV Hope was
sitting on that block I'd use it too so
okay so you think do you think that's
why it rocked the house so much because
they brand new
yeah they def it definitely helped draw
the lines in the house uh I mean now the
ladies are on one side the crowns on the
other and you've got a couple people in
the middle so it's going to get
interesting that's for sure
now you told ty not to be you know not
to be sorry about putting you up as a
replacement boat you know why do you
think you were the replacement Nam
well I feel like Tai doesn't have any
ties in the house anymore he doesn't
have any people he can genuinely trust
because of the first couple weeks the
the way they went uh so he's trying to
mend Bridges and trying to build
relationships with Koozie Daniel C and
Anika so he felt like you know if he had
to put one of them on the Block he
probably would have destroyed any chance
of building a relationship with them and
he knew after the POV that he could not
build a relationship with the ladies so
uh I felt like he he felt that I was the
only choice to go on the Block I know I
wasn't his Target at the beginning of
this week but a lot of things happened
and here I will here I am so do you
think Tai still needs to not be sorry
after the result of the vote
I you know I you know leaving the house
I feel I've seen a few tears in these
eyes uh I mean I think he's regretting
it and moving forward in the game I
would have been open to working with him
because genuinely I do like Tai uh our
games crossed early on in the game and
some things happen but uh I feel like we
genuinely liked each other I would have
been willing to work with him in the
future uh but uh it is what it is and
I'm sitting here talking to you so I'm
definitely not upset with that so yeah
thank you
ah you're a charmer all right well
can you explain a bit about what it felt
like to sit next to Hope on the Block
and
how you had to adjust your campaign
it was tricky you know uh first at first
when I sat next to my I was upset I was
I was sad but uh I started looking at it
in a different light I mean if I'm gonna
go out and I'm sitting next to someone
that I genuinely care about in that game
I mean if I had to pick that's the way I
want to go out I mean I wanna
like right before I left I told him I
said do what's best for you be the man
you want to be in this game and push
forward as hope uh so I'm rooting for
him uh we're not campaign I campaign for
me but I also didn't want to you know
hurt his game in any way so it was
definitely a different experience but uh
at the end of the day if I was to leave
the house that's the way I would have
chose so all right well I want to kind
of get into your brain a bit about you
know what your approach was in terms of
campaigning you know with someone like
Shanaya or Claudia versus someone like
Santina
okay okay
I will
well Santina or no sorry shanea and
Claudia I kind of felt like I could get
their vote because after the POV they
were hungry for a good number and they
felt like I was that good number and you
know Claudia is my East Coast connect
since day one we've looked out for each
other we have a brother sister
relationship and uh so I felt like she
immediately trusted me and she wanted me
in that house so I kind of didn't have
to campaign too hard too high to the
ladies but uh the ladies Alliance but uh
and Santina was a little tricky because
she felt like Hope was better for her
game because she felt like he was
connected to both sides of the house
without me
I didn't tell her but I was even more
connected to both sides of the house but
I kind of left it be because
I just wanted her to make her own
decision and you know at the end of the
day her decision is her decision and
she could have went either way I wasn't
too sure but uh you know I'm I'm living
with it and I'm hoping that it benefits
her game in the house doesn't hurt her
but uh I guess we'll see how everything
turns out
all right well we have been seeing a lot
of drama the last couple of weeks in the
house I got I'm just gonna switch gears
because I gotta talk about the drama
this is Big Brother uh who do you
believe in that house is really stirring
the pot right now Jonathan
stirring the pot I would have to go with
Renee I think that right now she's
really digging deep into her game and
respectfully so I mean she's she's she
was on the Block three three times now
so I feel like she's really digging deep
into her game uh and also I'll have to
go with Todd I feel like Ty is trying to
figure out his game plan moving forward
at the beginning of this game he really
came in aggressive and started trying to
push his will on the game and I feel
like that hurt him and it hurt him in a
lot of ways and with a lot of people in
the house so he's really trying to you
know set seeds and people of Doubt
because he don't want to Target on his
back so uh yeah I would have to go with
maybe Renee and Ty as the people that
are trying to mix the house up right now
and get the targets off the back all
right well this is interesting now I got
another question for you who do you
think butts heads the most in the house
oh right now yeah right now I'm gonna
have to go with Koozie and Renee
there's a there's there's things
happening there right now two of them
are destined the bump heads uh but uh
also uh
yeah Santina she is not afraid to fight
she she's if someone comes off the wrong
way or she expects something she's not
afraid to oppose her will on that either
but uh in bump heads I would have to go
with Koozie and Renee for sure okay give
me a little insight like give me a
little give me a little house t on that
Jonathan why do you think that these two
bump heads so much what's what's brewing
well you got two women that really want
to win this game right so and two
powerful strong women like I you know uh
so and throughout the fight now like you
know it's later in the game the lines
are dry and uh I feel like Koozie uh
being a leader that she is feels like
Renee is threatening her our alliance to
Crown so and Koozie is not afraid of
fight she is strong-willed she shows
great leadership skills and she sees
Renee as a social threat and Renee is
kind of walking around the house since
she got off the block but she kind of
owns it so it's kind of rubbing Koozie
the wrong way
and hey when
when you know in that house emotions are
high so uh I'm excited to see how that
pans out for sure all right all right
okay well let's talk a bit about your
speech you gave a beautiful and powerful
thank you about the importance of your
experience in the house
um with your house guests did you you
know did you just want to speak to the
experience and thank them or did you
kind of have a feeling that you were
going home
um I kind of had the vibe that I was
going home so I just really wanted to
stress that how important the time in
the house was to me and each and every
relationship I built I mean even in the
crown for example the diversity of that
was something I was so proud of you had
people from not only all over Canada but
all over the world and for me to be part
of that I mean I'm a newfoundlander from
Canada to be part of that Crown Alliance
and why people stood for in that house
uh I mean that's something I'll carry
with me long after the show and I'm so
proud of it and that's exactly what I
wanted coming into this game I came in
with the mindset of getting to know
people that I would never meet in my
regular life and I I accomplished that
and I build friendships that are
stronger than I ever could have imagined
and I'm excited to see who stands tall
at the end I'm excited for people to
come in the jury and finale and
everything that comes after so I'm
really excited about it amazing all
right well listen you're not out of the
game yet you are in jury you know you've
got decisions to be made Aid all the
things so I guess I gotta ask you what
or who do you think what makes a winner
of bbcan 11 and who do you think is
going to win bbcan 11.
poor well I would have to say someone
that's willing to make the hard
decisions uh someone that shows great
leadership skills that people can follow
and don't feel pressured to follow uh
someone that's you know looked upon as a
strong asset in the game and to me
personally I think that's Koozie Queen
Koozie I think she has a strong run at
the end of this and I believe that when
finale comes I'm gonna see her Stand
Tall but uh yeah I mean I'm excited for
people to trickle in the jury to see
their aspect of the game and everyone
discuss things and see who played the
best game but you definitely need
strategy but you need to be able to
adjust on the flaw you can't just think
one way you got to be able to adjust the
different moves different situations
different emotions and you know like
this past week things happened and I was
on the Block and I got evicted I did not
see that coming so you really got to be
able to adjust in this game for sure
absolutely
well thank you so much again Jonathan
you are now officially a part of the BB
can family so welcome and you made it to
jury so you've had an incredible journey
so far and there's still more to
experience so I know enjoy the rest of
the incredible season and congrats to
you and PS you look very beautiful
thank you so much thank you so much